dandy walker malformation is a
congenital defect in the cellum a brain
region responsible for balance and
coordination so in the dandy walker
malformation there are many problems
cystic dilation of the fourth ventricle
hypoplasia of the cere vermis
enlargement of the posterior for fosa
and a cystic bulge at the back of the
head is pretty
distinct this is a normal MRI of a
normal baby this is how the cerebelum
look like and look at this in a dandy
walker malformation case the cerebelum
hypoplasia is pretty distinct along with
a enlarged cystic fourth ventricle and
this kind of cystic dilation occurs due
to high due to obstruction of the
cerebros spinal fluid flow there could
be coordination problem developmental
delays behavioral defects and a shunt
can improvise the situation